المزيد من المساعدات الدوليه تصل الى باب
الهوى كل يوم تتسلمها المنظمات الشريكه
للامم المتحده لتوزيعها في المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال شمال غرب سوريا لا
يتحدث سائق الشاحنات عن اي صعوبات تعترضهم
وتحمل الشاحنات مساعدات طبيه وخياما ومواد
غذائيه
سيتم تجهيز مواد غذائيه اساسيه وكذلك
بطاريات وفرش وخيام اليوم تم استلام قرابه
400 خيمه من صندوق قطر التنميه ست وصلت
على على الطائرات القطريه سيتم ان شاء
الله
ادخالها في اليوم الثاني لداخل السوري
وانشاء مخيم للعوائل التي هي في العراق
بسرعه يبني المتطوعون خيمه وينتقلون الى
اخرى كذلك تعمل المنظمات الشريكه مع الامم
المتحده على ايواء العائلات في مخيمات
وتزويدها بوسائل التدفئه كي لا تبقى في
العراء وسط البرد لكن المتضررين من
الزلزال توزعوا على مناطق متفرقه هنا في
منطقه جسر الشغور اقيم لهم مركز ايواء وسط
المخيم يحاول سكان المخيم تقديم العون لهم
لكن ما يشغل بال فاطمه هو ابقاء ابنتي هذا
فئتين عندما يغيب الاب للبحث عن مسكن افضل
طلعنا معها العالم كان مطر ونحن بيتنا اكل
صاروخ
وبعد ما صارت الهزه زاد بزياده هر الحجر
والاولاد ما عرفنا كيف طلعناهم بالليل
ومطر وليل جابونا لهون
وبعدها ما معنا الاغراض ولا شيء جبنا بس
الاولادي
بدنا صوبه بدنا حطب اسفنجات ما طلعنا شيء
ابدا معنا حتى ثياب ما طلعنا معنا
وامام قسوه الاحوال ينشغل الجميع عن
المعاناه التي يعيشها كبار السن جراح
عميقه يعانيها المتضررون من الزلزال
يقولون انما يساعدهم على تجاوز الالم هو
اعاده اعمار بيوتهم وليست اي مساعدات اخرى
صاحب الخلف الجزيره ريف ادلب